quel même là ça demande une réponse de
gérald gordat et notamment sur la sphère
de chalon sur saône vous êtes conseiller
régional on peut rappeler ump vous vous
l'avez soutenu vous gilles platret quand
il a fait cette affaire j'ai pas le
soutenir avant le soutenir il était dans
son action de maire de chalon sur saône
mais la peau et nicolas sarkozy l'a
approuvé alors est ce que vous valez
sarkozy je n'ai je ne vais ni approuvé
ni désapprouvé c'était son affaire à
chalon sur saône
néanmoins ce qui ce qu'on peut dire sur
d'après tout ce qu'on a entendu à
l'instant c'est que ce qui nous a fait
gagner la droite et en saône et loire
mais également dans les autres
départements
c'est le rassemblement c'est l'union de
la droite et du centre est d'arriver à
montrer une véritable image unie
quelques exceptions près évidemment
penser à la chapelle de guinchay par
exemple m'est arrivé à montrer une image
unie d'adapter du centre nous a permis
de gagner et nous a permis aussi de
faire des très bons scores dans des
bastions de la gauche je pense au
creusot ou à 300 voix près on est prêt à
faire basculer à montceau les mines dans
ce quasi kazan et basculer des quasi
inimaginable évidemment avec eux les
municipales à gueugnon 46% pour la
droite
inimaginable aussi donc mais aussi on a
vraiment eu un travail de fond qu'on a
mené parce que on a aussi travers on a
une traversée du désert on a mené après
travail de rassemblement et c'est ce qui
nous a permis de gagner ce soir c'est
vrai et pour les régionales tout de
suite bonne leçon à tenir le
rassemblement